[Music]
take me gravity
[Music]
luca is the story of a young sea monster
who really wants to be a human boy and
it's about him and his best friend
alberto navigating an adventure into the
human world
hello my name is enrico cazaroza and i
am the director of disney and pixar's
luca
here we are in a scene toward the end of
act 2. the idea here is that our two
protagonists luca and alberto are
starting to uh really ghost their
separate way and starting to have
conflict julia is of course
becoming the person that is in between
them luca is learning a lot more from
her about this human world alberto
doesn't really know about the human
world that well so he's starting to feel
more and more jealous
so when we started writing this scene we
wanted already to kind of twist a little
bit of a knife into alberto so luca asks
about the train uh this idea of us going
to school with julia is of course
the antithesis of everything that
alberto wants alberto wants to keep his
friend so he's very afraid
and so at the beginning here was all
about
showing how alberto is really annoyed at
luca's interest at anything that julia
does of course this pushes alberto to do
something is very dangerous well then
what does he need me we'll just ride it
like we did on the island together
the scene is not only mirroring the
first time they do this on the island
but it's also exactly the same set where
a few scenes later we're gonna have the
climax of the movie so it really maps
out lucas change he's very
scared and he needs alberto to lead him
down the first time gary's still
struggling with it and alberto kind of
takes him down the wrong way in a
dangerous way and ultimately in the
third act right in this spot he not only
will lead down without fear but he's
gonna save alberto and on top of that
even be willing to show his sea monster
self
the other really fun part of this crazy
ride
was seeing the town we knew that the
town had to be alive the town is the
whole character and we look for
opportunities to bring these specifics
of a small italian town the old man
playing chess
between story artists that come up with
these wonderful gags and then animators
that even add something to the last
minute
for example the lemons that end up in
their faces right that's not something
that happens right away on the page or
even in storyboards sometimes it really
happens as we start
working with the animators and then i
love that little alley they go through
at the end because it just felt like
such a portal and it's very very typical
if you go to cinque terre you're gonna
totally feel like you've been already if
you watched luca a couple of times
[Music]
what was that it was important to set up
eric lee hearing something and
activating that that was the goal of
that moment that we we were trying to
figure out how to best do it because he
couldn't see them but he had to really
you have to buy then a couple of minutes
later is gonna show up because he's
looking around and of course the fun of
chicha offering a focaccia we joke in uh
in the whole uh movie nobody eats a
focaccia sandwich it's like every single
sandwich aircraft is around gets kicked
away or he's about to bite it and he put
you know puts it away but then of course
he had this dangerous moment it's like
oh julia could see us and that's when
we're starting to build lucas
frustration interestingly this shot was
very very difficult because it just felt
like julia was seeing them very clearly
so this show was full of little cheats i
think that we had to move julia quite a
bit further away from where she was
literally she'll see us come on
this is the beginning of the scene we
used to call it splash it's really where
things are coming to a head you crashed
into the sea it's fine nothing's fine
all of the color palette was so much fun
to really um think deeply about we do a
a whole caller script for the whole
movie that maps
around emotions of different scenes we
were quite careful to not set that many
scenes at sunset so that this
created a contrast and a sense of drama
we knew that it would be supported
wonderfully by very very saturated
yellows and oranges the waves are a
wonderful little thing we did here
because we never did waves like that
anywhere else in the movie you will
notice almost every single at the scene
has pretty calm waves here we allow the
effects team to just give us
turmoil you know we want it of course to
feel even the nature and the weather is
is feeling the conflict shut up
[Music]
we had a lot of discussions with our
story team that from day one they this
is a kids movie they will have to go to
blows at some point they should have a
fight i love that bite by the way
because it just like it was a hint of
comedy in the middle of pathos we had
long discussions about whether it should
be dramatic or also a little bit playful
and goofy and i really was
one of those two things side by side
for a long time alberto wasn't gonna be
about to take a swing and i remember
pete doctor had this wonderful
suggestion like tell me the fight is
gonna continue
and so we kind of made a little
adjustment to this animation like he's
gonna really punch him which i always
thought it's it's such a wonderful note
[Music]
this shot is actually mirrored
in our finale in our goodbye it's a very
similar show where she hugs both of them
at the train station
um
i always loved this one was boarded as
was and they just you know the way they
look at each other
divided by her it's so wonderful
you know in this version of the scene of
course alberto is going to really reveal
their biggest secret so it's really
betraying luca in many ways
i've always been very proud of the fact
that this feels like a sudden choice but
even more so the choice of luca
to disown him this is luka denying
himself i knew this was a monster
did you hear that this way and of course
we wanted him to even twist the knife in
you know what have i done we wanted to
feel the emotion of luca like oh my gosh
i caused this and i almost got my friend
killed interestingly we didn't
immediately script it that way we had
scripted it in a way where alberto was
dragging luka and and betraying him and
of course julia
would know both of their secrets and we
realized that that kind of put luca very
mad at alberto but it actually made our
protagonist a little bit non-active he
was more of a victim
as soon as we thought of actually
allowing luca to do worse than alberto i
mean it activated
this surprise first of all because like
i think we were used to the other way so
i think we
we didn't see it coming and i think a
lot of people feel this is a surprising
moment
and allowing him to do the wrong thing
we even had a few people kind of doubt
that this could work because it was so
callous of luca to do this but you know
now he could make it up to alberto you
would have to try actually was really
all about trying to get alberto back
what are you doing i'm okay
i'll be back tomorrow i'm gonna fix this
it's really strange and and wonderful to
watch the scene you know after so many
months what i love the most about it is
that it's surprising and that's an
important thing making these movies
audiences are so sophisticated and i
hope it does surprise new audiences when
they see this moment of betrayal and
again hopefully then
give us the jews to really want to see
luca succeed in winning back alberto and
actually
[Music]
you